we're in the village of Gandhi in the
far north of Nigeria it's not far from
the Sahara and the desert is advancing
southwards at an estimated 600 meters
per year it's already started
encroaching on Gandhi and surroundings
this village is home to de hero the
farmer has spent his entire life here he
tells us he's worried about the growing
threat from the desert in the north and
his annual harvest is dwindling year
after year las yeah I think taking just
a politically let's see 400 but max how
many do you think you get this this year
I presume Italy 300 hellos gasps care of
25% over last year's group
the encroachment is more than this and I
just statin let the water am it you can
be able to go there is a one time we
will go tomorrow try and visit care if
he basically only show you how do this
is important and when it leaves it is
more than three kilometers annually the
farmer hires hurts meant to graze their
cattle on his land so he can collect the
manure for fertilizer and he's doing
more to wood of the deserts and we as
individuals why must I Plantin you know
are pounds just to reduce the level
encouragement that's what you can do and
you dizzy see all these neem trees I
planted whereas Nigeria has been
fighting their certification for decades
the government has a special budget for
forestry programs and has planted 200
kilometers of tree barriers in recent
years every year we ensure that
plantation takes place throughout the
year we don't just plant trees Julian
rainy season it means you really dry
season we'll get trees the cluster of
trees are planted at designated
locations to hold back the desert winds
that carry the sand but residents of
many rural communities continue to cut
down trees to use the word for charcoal
burning desert ification displaces
communities and threatens people's
livelihoods it's estimated that Nigeria
loses more than 5 billion dollars a year
as a result more sustainable solutions
are needed to successfully hold back the
advancing desert and the destruction it
causes